The Game of Thrones finale left a lot of viewers
asking questions, and now some of them have
been answered, thanks to the release of the
episode's script.
Here's a look at some of the most surprising
small details uncovered in its pages.
After the Game of Thrones finale aired, fans
hurried online to try and find an answer to
one huge lingering question about the destruction
of the Iron Throne.
Did Drogon intentionally destroy the Iron
Throne because he recognized it as the reason
for Daenerys' downfall?
Or was he just a big dumb animal lashing out?
Turns out that big dragon is just a big, dumb
animal.
In the script, showrunners David Benioff and
D.B. Weiss wrote that Drogon wanted to burn
the world, saying,
"We look over Jon's shoulder as the fire sweeps
toward the throne not the target of Drogon's
wrath, just a dumb bystander caught up in
the conflagration."
So for anyone looking for some kind of meaning
in these events: there isn't any!
One thing that chapped a lot of hides was
the fact that we never got a sense of what
Daenerys was feeling or thinking after she
went on her rampage in the penultimate episode.
The finale script unfortunately doesn't offer
any insight either: from the moment Jon enters
the throne room in her final scene, the script
doesn't give any hint of Dany's point of view,
focusing entirely on Jon Snow.
Fans who were upset at Daenerys' lack of dialogue
during the siege of King's Landing probably
won't be any happier knowing the dragon queen
didn't even get an inner monologue while she
was being stabbed to death.
Over the course of the show, Daenerys certainly
acquired plenty of lofty titles.
"You stand in the presence of Daenerys Stormborn
of House Targaryen, rightful heir to the Iron
Throne, rightful queen of the Andals and the
First Men..."
Like... a lot of them.
"...Protector of the Seven Kingdoms, the Mother
of Dragons, the Khaleesi of the great Grass
Sea, the Unburnt, the Breaker of Chains."
But while many fans were calling her the Mad
Queen at the end, just as her father before
her was the Mad King, the script actually
gave her a more unexpected title during the
finale: "Her Satanic Majesty."
Yep!
While describing the scene where Dany lords
over her conquered city, the script read:
"For a moment, Drogon's unfolding wings spread
behind her back, an unsettling image.
Her Satanic Majesty's Request."
That's actually a reference to the 1967 Rolling
Stones album Their Satanic Majesties Request,
which contains a lot of trippy imagery.
One of the most haunting sequences in the
Game of Thrones finale is Tyrion's long walk
through the ruins of King's Landing.
Benioff and Weiss deliberately packed this
part of the script with cultural and historical
references to give it added oomph.
The focus on Tyrion's face, for instance,
was inspired by the 2015 Holocaust drama Son
of Saul.
The script read,
"We follow him Son of Saul style, tight on
his face as he passes through the gates."
And a few lines later, the directions reference
another tragedy from World War II, the atomic
bombing of Hiroshima, Japan, saying,
"Human silhouettes on the dragon-scorched
ground where the ashes have blown away, the
negative image of the Hiroshima silhouettes."
One place the script does provide important
nuance is that weird council meeting where
the heads of the noble families of Westeros
somehow ended up electing Bran as King.
It seemed a bit random to many fans, but the
script provides some much needed explanation
as to why the council voted that way.
Edmure Tully, Bran's uncle, is
"[...] miffed he wasn't given serious consideration,
but he expects he'll have influence at court
if his crippled nephew is ruling."
Meanwhile, Gendry is, quote, "happy to go
along," while Yara Greyjoy has apparently,
"[...] heard that her brother died defending
Bran.
She knows this choice would make Theon happy."
Finally, Brienne of Tarth is, quote, "a Stark
loyalist."
One person who doesn't get a lot of development?
That random new Prince of Dorne, who is such
a nonentity that even the script doesn't bother
giving him a name.
Sorry, whoever you are!
If you thought it was weird that Bran became
king, well, Weiss and Benioff agreed, as the
script itself noted more than once how odd
this plot twist was.
Remember when Tyrion offered him the crown?
"Will you wear the crown?"
"Why do you think I came all this way?"
In the script, it then said,
"A strange response but Tyrion has come to
expect strange answers from Bran."
Then, in the small council meeting, after
asking where Drogon is, Bran drops this:
"Perhaps I can find him."
In the script, this is followed by a note
reading
"That's weird.
But so is the new king."
Also weird?
The fact that Sam is wearing Grandmaester
robes even though he never completed his training.
But the script makes it clear that he is indeed
a Grandmaester despite his limited qualifications.
When Sam enters the small council chamber,
the script notes,
"[...] he wears the Grandmaester robes and
a chain with a single healing link."
At least someone in this show got a happy
ending.
At the end of the show, Jon Snow was exiled
to the far north as he rejoins the Night's
Watch.
We end the series with Jon and his wildling
friends wandering past the wall.
Considering there seemed to be no reason to
even have a Night's Watch any more, that led
some fans to think he was taking his place
as the King Beyond the Wall.
But the script seems to suggest he's just
a regular schmoe, as it unequivocally calls
him a "Night's Watchman" rather than a King.
Considering the fate of most monarchs on the
show, though, that's probably for the best.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.